jean condom se retrouve au niveau
nouvelle vidéo donc kabbage puise alors
on apprécie aujourd'hui sur le montage
on a décidé de faire simple en trois
épisodes de vous faire une seule vidéo
de 35 à 38 3 4 vidéos dans guateri 3 on
verra bien de toute façon ça dépend de
comment va à l'étrier donc en tout cas
au motion va vous proposer dans ce
premier épisode des interviews des plus
grands tubes heures des grandes chaînes
comme le permis par exemple telles que
la paix comedy club comme qg amateurs
issus de campagne tout ça le vous allez
voir que nous donner leur avis sur
modern warfare 3 et c'était choquant
qu'elle ceinturant du petit luca
vainqueur et on a bien parlé habitués
bien enfin bref c'était quelque chose de
vraiment très bien j'espère que vous
aussi si vous y êtes allé vous a déclaté
celui y est pas allé main directe aux
cages vides à l'insa milieu bio en tout
cas là sur ce premier épisode est au
renouveau 0 deuxième épisode sur mumbai
bombay la paris games week avec mon ami
arnaud
ait ben alors montre devant nous il ya
personne
il est alors il est à peu près huit
heures la paris games week
se faire doubler d'ailleurs
quitte à parfois et
qu'en pense qu'arnaud
parfait
je
vidéo
non
oh
ok
surtout
avec eux
hamama
salon
les vols charters
tu en penses quoi
à
mes yeux
inutile
la maîtrise pas
oui
seven hills et je leur en parler alors à
mort très jeune
passé pour savoir ce qu'ils pensent vos
lèvres à trois fois pour attester
ce matin
ouais je
le coeur
les armoires
ben ali
je vais
bien planté
ouais
apte à bien l'aimer
sa mère devant
marçais
franchement j'ai bien accroché c'est
super
rien
franchement
modèle franchement ça fait moins 10 des
semeurs originale pour les bottes
le jeu
la caméra
hélas oui
est ce que tes terres
énorme
plein d'énergie plus
sanaa
entre battlefield 3 est maintenant faire
toi tu achèterais le quai
voilà c'était ce quiz était maintenant
m'interroge m'assure mid
ouais
ni à faire dans sa férule des tortues
gallois
franchement au début quand je regardais
les vidéos sur un cône sujet sur toutes
les chaînes pour la victoire
pensez vraiment que ça les nourrit vraie
copie de moderne en forte hausse
pas du tout en fait
heureusement way est sérieux
donné les énormes va parfois de l'espace
de chute
c'est l'une de mes préférées
déçu mais sinon il est vraiment
magnifique ce 16
ben moi je pense à peu près la même
chose
koné
regardez
alors voilà les bergers dollars demandés
mais après
comme seuls t-shirt d'accord alors je
crois
une fois dans leur sphère de
on améliorer
la précédente
pour l'acheter
magnifique repousse vers de corneille
matra et perdurer
le mode furie des moments bien
on les oublie pas
en tout cas merci à tous
oui on ci dessus voilà évidemment on
après vous
les invite à passer sa vie tu as passé
voir la critique
nous annoncerons tél
bye
oui
d
belga
quand
joyeuse
je sais
la page
là
ayem a pas
ce quiz il se doit avec petit je mentais
le mois saint
ce mot à dire
moi et émotionnel
m
au fait ça
avec aujourd'hui personnels sont prêts
du jamais vu
baiser
on a signé avec nous
chacun parce que je vais juste trois ans
et trois schémas
reste à présent
hubert chose
sortir comment
passage doit bien
jean le vieux hangar malouda
à vous les studios
edit eu cette phrase
d'abord
non alors
comme je n'étais jamais accès
là
exemple ne prennent pas
mais en politique
façon de
parce qu'on s'est fait pincer
pense que pas assez
non
je pense qu'un
on annonce que j'étais
vous êtes
giroux
quand
je veux
suite
avec
bayer
marché
tu as
je n'ai pas compris
pourquoi
à la barre hier à turin
et bien voilà c'est déjà la fin du
premier épisode on espère qu'ils savent
qu'ils ont la plus de voir les avis des
grimpeurs et des grandes chaînes sur
modern warfare 3 ainsi que sur le salon
de la paris games week du rize acciona
bien moi je vais passer un super week
end accompagner dans d'autres c'est tout
ce que nous ne sur la vidéo c'est
devient
non au sima samar volage en tout cas en
décembre aussi personnellement je
remercie tous sauvés et tous ceux et
toutes celles qui auront reconnu comme
s'il y avait un film à rechercher qu'il
m'avait pas trop eu à prendre on s'en
fout et puis puis maculé je vous
remercie tous de bain noir pour ceux qui
m'ont reconnu la même des gens qui ont
voulu se cotiser pour montrer quelque
chose moi justement c'était vraiment
quelque chose de l'encourager lui sont
ceux qui vont demander des autographes
ces banques ont reconnu ce qu'ils m'ont
demandé d'essayer des trucs premier
poteau sa faim voilà ça m'a vraiment
étonné parce que c'est un scan du
virtuel commune hadzic iso du corps on
voit ça dans la vraie vie les gens qui
viennent vers nous qui nous
reconnaissent qu'ils vont un squeeze le
considère comme come on people en
quelques jours même le père de quelqu'un
à la fin de dinan qui marque dont
j'avais donné je suis de 10 ans et carys
ce qui m'arrive et qui tient l'est qui
me fait d'ailleurs amené dans big up à
cette personne de tison qui fait
vraiment vraiment très sympa et super kf
qui fait je sais pas ce qu'est ce que
vous faites sortir mon fils est
passionné vous faites beaucoup et j'ai
envie de dire surtout monsieur n'allait
pas ce que je fais
de fait les groupes impliqués dans les
bio et nouveaux lieux vers qui la loire
c'est enfin moi en tout cas passé en
discute et on se retrouve demain pour
l'épisode 2 du paris games week et là ça
va être quelque chose tpiy quelque chose
d'incroyable qu'il n'aurait jamais vu je
vous assure qu'à voir ça je ne serai
jamais jamais vu c'est pas possible
c'est techniquement pas possible depuis
à ça vous fera bien rire
et puis et puis bah on se quitte sur ça
et on vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée jazz de mon mari